there's a conspiracy theory going on
right now but what about you but I do
now know it was that one of your fights
and there's someone in the crowd with a
camera phone yes look at that
come on that's a pong nothing like that
come on son this is Photoshop Photoshop
Photoshop VHS all right we're here for
hot boxing and we have such a rave guest
here today
right now we have onyx here we have
sticky fingers me and Fred drone we got
Johnny vogue over here new artist coming
up Johnny how you feel about all this
time I ain't even doing this traveling
stuff hanging with these dudes man
oh we got on tour last well October we
ran through by 10 countries together
I've never even been outside the country
so it's really easy plus you taller than
everybody I'm six-three so I'm talking
everybody I'm Puerto Rican braids
but they love what the boy has but you
know I I do it for the for the long hair
don't care two valves open enough oh man
yeah like 20 cities whose crazy Budapest
Portugal France Paris yeah my mother was
[ __ ] in the tea you know it's crazy you
ever think you know you wanted you want
to thank you or assume you're gonna be
somebody but no one is when it's there
and then and then with them like rock
stars over there so we got security
bringing me to the mall I'm like fragile
I don't know bring to the world
you in love that's a [ __ ] around
blowing up it's almost like a fantasy
right yeah you know you gotta learn from
others but it can be done it can be done
if you don't do it mom the merge
everything is independent is we cut the
middleman out and everything sneaked
easy the storing laws I'm sorry [ __ ]
because he came in as an independent you
know saying coming with his hand out he
came in as like let's bill with this
young proper you know I'm saying that's
what we saw I'm Bob with him I went to a
couple show they had a show companies
among the labels amongst is my hand we
if we if you could do it without him
that's the goal Oh eventually you gonna
need someone special day for you my
trying to get him again smokey smoke
before he grabs me
you've been around long enough period
you guys experienced what what is it
that you teach young brother vogue over
here from what you experienced for your
losses from your wins from no [ __ ] that
man and the business that left you kind
of probably I don't know what's better
for a moment to yet to repeat yourself
you know there's always things I can
fight them that was bitter for a long
time dawn came talk grew up and say this
mean more than a dozen it's like me
taking a poison waiting for him to die
he's only hurting me right like you said
Oh got those contrary do it do it it's
like a bonus to point like a lot of
different reasons first of all do it for
yourself
number one okay because you can't please
nobody else and make nobody else happy
unless you happy I mean you gotta fix
your mass first you know and then do
whatever and then once you fix your mass
you gotta fix the next person smash too
you know
so after you do it for yourself that you
gotta do it for others you know and you
want to continue doing it successfully
and you wanna if you want to stop doing
it you want to live comfortably so save
your money don't you save it because if
you spend their money
he's got savings your savings gonna get
depleted too so you gotta invest it how
would you invest you my how you invest
your money well he came in with a hood
your hash he got a little cloak not
excuse me big clothing store in New York
yeah that's a cliche fight of here you
know so this is how they also teach me
25 year they they're doing hundreds of
shows it's ridiculous
the love they get overseas is ridiculous
they discovered the rest of the world
and they were rocking ever so listen man
yeah much hey I love over here just the
ring thing trying to give them the love
that they get over there exactly that's
often overrated maybe but they have no
egos either guy has no ego these guys
have no ego typical rappers as emcees
all got egos for the future make a
future will come think for because oh
it's coming after a while you're like oh
gee you don't I'm saying do you like
damn if I would've thought for the
future
[ __ ] me think about what's
gonna happen today at that moment right
there that you know I'm saying that puts
right there that's that because they
think about the future but listen right
this is what I've learned in life from
handling money is art none of us none of
us ever had money nobody I'm told black
white people everybody oh my god these
bombs all day the first Rockefeller
right he was spinning like would mean
the dogs on his garden this year he's
been but Jen taxes came in like what
1909 19 in 1909 1910 taxes King and so
all the robber barons all those guys
like the Rockefeller to do personal
they're all [ __ ] up these taxes
started [ __ ] them up and so this guy
this one guy named JP Morgan know what
he did he bailed us out of our debt so
now he don't know why he doesn't get
taxed we had to come have to pay him
back [ __ ] on his crew and family ever
get taxed so that's not a game that's
that's how dumb
that's not most of the robber barons
they gotten involved with government
then before the government used to like
get a Rosa Rosa he's always shut down
the robber barons G hated john d
rockefeller knows because they had so
much money but he had the power to break
his monopolies up you know yeah and
those guys set the rest of the world
that's why oil is still used in cause I
haven't back of my own cannabis theory
because of course the whole entire hep
car was built and I would that's right
they don't want they don't want to
biodegradable fuel why would they give
that up but they had the head start they
were the first billionaire well the
first guy maybe the kids after him but
the first guy he was a lady but he
thought he was better than everybody
nobody really [ __ ] with him every
month well he had all these paper trees
so he worked with this guy Harry
Anslinger to shut down renovate yeah
yeah because he didn't want hemp to be
he wanted to make it illegal because
they could use hemp to build anything
you know the robber baron guy they
didn't believe in you didn't weed and
all that stuff it was like drugs like
cocaine they come like hurts like he
would have parties they come to the
biggest celebrities in the world be up
there but he said yo guys can't be in a
room with women they wouldn't let my
children what do you mean we can't marry
David slept in his room but no one else
no Cary Grant all these guys Clark Gable
he can't sleep what they want what [ __ ]
I know he was [ __ ] sleeping together
anyway like this yeah he was he was an
eccentric dude have you ever been there
the Hearst Castle hey Mike you ever
heard the holy anointing oil theory
coming brother
I'm always like this is my father
staring like he's been studying this
forever now this I'm gonna I'm gonna
miss quota he gonna slap me in the head
when I get back but um it's about Jesus
Christ in the Bible that it was an oil
that he was only given to the rich that
helps supposed to cure pain things that
I had a church and that's what Jesus
Christ fought for for things like that
that should also go to the poor not only
the rich I'm asking but the holy
anointing oil no you know and it's
almost like you died for it and Jesus
family we were dealing Orioles back
narrow oil is back to be here judo is
turf you know but I don't know I don't
know anything about at that particular
town you know when I know we came in
came in existed really in 1902 in Saudi
Arabia they were all broken stuff and in
1902 they discovered oil I know one
thing my pops used to put oil on my head
when I used to go outside be like yo dad
I'm going out into the streets he be
like come here boy what you doing put
some oil on your forehead and I come
home I believe in you first you gotta
know how to move out there industries
you gotta understand that's the best way
to make it you know you guys all know
each other yeah yeah it was in a club
and he was just like I'm born 84 so I
missed you I missed your prime prime but
I got 84 with 1884 I'm always I wish I
was oh let me tell you it's always I see
myself getting older and stuff I got
them this is great this can't be what
the [ __ ] happened to that time actually
believe with that really mix out I
forgot about all that [ __ ] you know it's
funny I stay up watching this podcast
and old fights I'm like a waiter like I
watch fights like I'm training this you
know like you did back in the days
watching Jack Dempsey and the rest of
them but I literally watched fights but
it's crazy because I see the transition
from one video to the next one you know
he's fighting what was they pink victim
Pinklon Thomas knocking him out with a
quick body uppercut that started ish but
uh and then all of a sudden I'm watching
this show and you got the bed the tan is
gone you know it's crazy
it goes by like this no no you see that
man if I'm alive a blessed man I'm here
now also would imagine y'all did that
today you can't do that was why
Instagram
[ __ ] a bunch of people are behind you
what me
people's word there's a conspiracy
theory going on right now but what about
you but I do now no it was at one of
your fights in the 90s I forget what
fight it was Bruce Seldon no but either
way and there's someone in the crowd
with a camera phone one of these yes
yeah did you see ya then trip you up to
my town
no need a guy hit him don't hit it
looked like a iPhone in the crowd with
the light on in 95 you know cameras back
then with big what's the big cassette
slap it in you know look like these guys
even these are small so that was crazy I
don't know if you know about that yeah
that's well yeah see right camera phone
types we've got it we're gonna make time
travel yet do time time traveler yeah
I'm surprised you saw it it's like one
of you want you in the ring how do you
you don't see nothing now here you see
in the ring is seen here everything you
do you see people sitting around that's
crazy
I don't think that I would think there
was relaxed and calm so you was just
like without another day in the office
type [ __ ] yo what up yeah he come in
different sometimes he just running away
okay it was classic though man no towel
no nothing it's coming out hey he when
he had the belt we strapped up look at a
guy phone that look like a samsung yeah
that's crazy right what and look how big
it is that look like an iPhone right
well galaxy oughta know no-bid right big
ass
what is that
I think Photoshop as well that ain't
Photoshop they got video isn't that fun
I think flag yeah video oh [ __ ]
1995 Oh McNeeley punkin
look at him avoiding your eyes phone on
I should've shown that the deep part
look at that
come on that's a phone it has nothing
like that back there
come on son this is Photoshop this a
Photoshop you can use Photoshop VHS man
look at my look at Isis part look at the
fade the hi fake that's all real so
Tyson here man that dude there - oh oh
look at that phone no no it'd be like
they watching an old fight on YouTube
and then BOOM it'd be like oh that
should look like the farm and then
should go viral commercial now the new
Galaxy fold Mike Tyson's first fight
Graz or as Peter McNeeley there's this
other thing I just saw the other day are
you high so holy blaze loosely spit wait
give some people some rapid I Spit my I
got songs were like oh we're artists
like Jadakiss but i saw on things like
that but i started with my brother Diggs
and we uh we used to rock out in the
group then him boom I don't know what he
said man let's just push the Vogel brand
so I went at it hard you know I'm around
with onyx that's why wrong with no you
know we only got one song
with the front and back stop the bullet
yes
therefore it's time for power what you
do so look at this painting here slave
painting so check out this guy down here
then slaves does that look like he's got
an iPhone yeah Emira watch it
this is this painting it's not 33 Christ
looking figure here the white Jesus
Christ
oh [ __ ] looking at it like he's taking
this up like he's reading the mirror
yeah it could be
Oh book he's reading something either
way there are theories
that's the roars tablet they look at
this guy shaving like the slave that's
definitely played for the Spanish yeah
this is a bell that's why somebody get
violated in that picture
oh no doubt about yeah check in the
middle right it's not good it's a whole
different movement you can find any
[ __ ] thing when you imagine if we had
that [ __ ] what was going on mean I
probably wouldn't make [ __ ] worse
so do you drive in New York well I'm I'm
from Long Island right on my alley but
there's no point in driving in New Delhi
traffic is worse you got you have to
yeah because your metro system ain't up
to par with the Cavs battles and Cavs
yeah going battery in your place
it's hard to see but catching kissing
all that crazy stuff that was my I know
a bunch of record label team Tyson yeah
we were really doing good stuff so what
made you guys wanna be rappers Randy no
not really
Rick Slick Rick or gnome yeah but how's
Italy back in America they get a deed in
my 23rd birthday party when I saw a
lottery that changed my life I lift the
ball and the ball he didn't do that one
caught that song like when he when he
performed it and do that song with the
ball
it's not for the shows the real grimy
[ __ ] they would they want that Roshi
well Sunset Park dude that was one of my
favorite movies I don't know what it was
on like I think HBO yeah all the time
that was a classic thing we are yo MTV
raps and all that [ __ ] fab 5 Freddy type
like MySpace type [ __ ] where you can
order some [ __ ] and really like wait for
your video it will come out that [ __ ]
was ill yeah you know I didn't even go
to the cameras went to p.m. dawn of
things yeah yes crazy
like it was a crazy night p.m. dawn with
the cool mellow rappers
okay that's just so slick he just you he
had I had this just setup with the DJ
cuz since as soon as he went onstage he
threw them [ __ ] off and the [ __ ]
played the bridges over like right on
point I was like yo that [ __ ] was ill
like some historical [ __ ] like many Boyd
even with MC Shannon them back in the
day no way so we play Ness you know but
sailor
he's always faking you don't have to say
that mean the whole Queen's knee but
visit the whole Queen oh that was rough
he killed Brooklyn oh but we all from
the same play that most of people in
Brooklyn ain't got relatives and queens
and everybody back and forth coming back
they get evicted I go to Queens and live
with their family now that's just how it
is you know like that all yeah yeah the
cousin hanging on breakfast for issues
indeed guys that's how I was in Brooklyn
was to cruise and pull my boys and the
cat and only one guy we're all friends
at the day our friends like killing each
is mine with one of my friends here and
I see my other friends from that side
time boom me both put my gun shooting
each other I'm down the Train my boys
never heard that he must be down other
guys like the katfoe with Ward Edith and
the Rutland rock whatever a dealer than
the pool boy those were Pumas [ __ ] got
sneakers my Pacific games killing each
other they're young kids this in
seventies man early eighties so Nike
wasn't even a party for the dope thing
got hot so it was Palmer's against
Adidas Nike wasn't even part of this to
my nerdiness brothers that this had
broke up I had actually also dealers now
no I think beaded improvements were
related happen didn't Polo and Tommy
Hilfiger was or what he did some went to
school together something like that yeah
it'd be like that I got the same Doda
yeah I got me to smoke we gonna get my
man to take a shot at handy at least oh
you know buddy
good morning smoke and go back to sleep
I think me and sticky two bottles and
brothers made off that's where it's
shown how to read and in the words
defenses are impregnable I said well
yeah 14:13 I came like my man Mike came
right out of institution this training
about reading have that like most I'm
speaking for most [ __ ] and we didn't
really like that no we had nobody to
teach us like them all just working
no I'm saying we are down and teach us
they [ __ ] Italian guy right and he would
tell me I'm he would see this white kid
everybody's guys think they're better
than you he was allowing me around them
he was you think you're stupid right
he's changed my whole perspective I know
that that perspective at the black kid
you know why guy gave me respect to the
man talking about this is what happened
in life and these people did this didn't
he he has put me on what happened right
oh jeez like Oscar I skipped a lot of
hit I skip history class I never liked
that she
that's opposite illusions crazy
audiences went bollocks
like your will [ __ ] 20 years ago like yo
for real like really like least black
don't crack I got three months left good
not about crap
good because I'm taking your experience
in perspective you know I mean and
having a vision of where you want to be
at a certain time in your life you know
after the goal Drive that's a fact we
don't dream we make play you know say
you know the evolution of the Mike Tyson
brain I was just peeping us our brands
our brand is elevators gonna evolve true
we gonna talk about that right yeah
you're gonna make some moves right talk
to me about some put on what we doing
I'm just saying we want to talk about
this on extreme you want to do the onyx
og we want to bring that [ __ ] to the
forefront that have any connection with
we do you have weed you have a dream I
love do we have we have a lot of
connections we do you have a strange you
have your strain out we don't have a
strain out yet that's what we want to
build with sure about you know I'm
saying we want to build with the the
masses of this [ __ ] why bill anybody
else right oh yeah stinky drove I swear
to god stinky now that I met you you how
the two smartest human I didn't know for
a fact this is only what I heard no I
never did any investigation and you
ain't front I'm in front
I've been told that over the years year
the year that man hear that for years I
owe over 20 years people telling me that
older people been telling me that right
and believe I but this made me you know
that that was true yeah a dolphin Rudo
good thing for [ __ ] Google
brother company no mom mother father
brothers that's crazy
brother my actual question was they
really fighting we do business well it's
gotta be why would you would you put so
much money towards a brand if your
brother got you can still be [ __ ] on
Thanksgiving when no money is real the
business turn oh yeah he became their
ride they were rivals guess wild be
rolled got to me is nothing could I
lived it but it's interesting this
I'm Eminem and Mars right I live next to
the leap Devine and they've been looked
them up they've been awards since the
beginning of their company mmm and Mars
M&M and Mars coke to Pepsi severed up
right yeah family members fighting
forever
oh that's part of this script right
everyday story right of the good stories
right no it's just that I'm people of
people right honey regardless your
brother your father all people we all
have drive the one we all need think
that's gonna stimulate a deep
intellectually physically you know I'm
gonna be one in one morning we want our
family sometimes
that's rough money is like paper blood
to some people listen that would be
their own no where would that one do
that with nor divine nature with nature
something back in they were 95 95 no
biggie if somebody for biggie something
you did is show some I
I wasn't old enough to kill three people
to get Joe
I saw one death for ODB out on the front
of the arm the club right oh yes he had
around listening he had at least a
hundred and this is no a hundred people
with him outside the club I'm talking
[ __ ] disrespectful to everybody
mmm [ __ ] I give you a but New York was
like that man we was coming hunted deep
to the spider security like y'all kill
everybody and next thing you know we
brush the whole door oh man everybody
boom everybody yeah put the guy you'll
want to toilet before we got our own
booking agency shot that my man Perry
shows a year overseas and [ __ ] yes
killing you know I'm saying like [ __ ]
Raylan that's the who's ten thousand
festival shout the Alpha fan we doing
some [ __ ] with them in Germany coming up
the immodesty shows every you guys
filling your we're selling merch all
that selling merch you know I'm saying
we just keeping the brand alive he's a
master j-shot skills big PS cuz Dane I
had to continue to brand but we the
brand has been rockin for 25 years since
93
you know I'm saying so we still keeping
a brand alive with the mad face we bred
into other day and big up in
rest in peace JJ who was the pioneer
yeah had us dressing different Hatter's
walking doing he was the style she used
to rock with our deep-sea units away
table when the obscene I mean these are
going to a night to follow be a Maiko
fall in their bus that's crazy
following a tour bus that a Rolls Royce
go with a red and a goddess man that's
dude they looking in their rearview
crying like I want to be like Mike no
cuz I see the few pictures like you with
the mess I didn't know many just fallen
though they had the beach Lee boy I was
just a fan yeah I have to play the music
before I going is going going to ring
and everything
in the mid-nineties hydration so when
the mid-nineties came well we did the
whole music scene now hip-hop first time
I heard rapper's delight' I was I was
locked up in spa his father the juvenile
detention center and I was locked to
miss puffing we heard on the radio we
said [ __ ] everybody starting dancing
what the [ __ ] was that
no listen hip-hop one time right
78 79 80 81 82 88 4 back that time if
you did you like you went ahead pop you
you're basically label the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] all the father people were
in there all the [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
they all went and the hip-hop club from
the Latin quarters and stuff like that
you know I mean that those are and was
that what was the arm placing
cue club the cute club in Queens yeah
that was my
yeah if I was wild off the hook but yeah
it was crazy how [ __ ] used to
shoot the club's up at New York back in
the day those like all just some random
lady was just waiting for it it happened
a lot more than that what more than it
is now
that's when um even though Nicky Barnes
and all those guys had their running
order the name King Billy
but I'm doing 80 that's one life wasn't
worth nothing man you'd have to be
careful what you said somebody what you
said there's a girlfriend you didn't
even know who you're talking at the be
careful even talk to your life wasn't
worth nothing your guys know regulate
with nothing in a it's a little but it
was an 80s I was like a baby and [ __ ]
I'm sure your mother yes um I was
telling you about drunk I killed a [ __ ]
next to a guy killer cousin for my guy
helicopters oh yeah you saw every saw
and understood what was going on you see
that [ __ ] and when we got out there cuz
I went to 40 do something I was 15 when
I was at 40 do so my whole life change
the first time I was introduced because
we just from Queens ain't none out there
it's his corner store that's it my man
will was the older neighbor of mine he
was like your age used to [ __ ] run
DMC and all that crazy [ __ ] he used to
take me with him you know I'm saying
it's just cocaine the door-latch it was
his little mannish it took me to the
deuce my whole life change I was like
listen when I went out to this my first
time since 7:00 late seventies right so
I'm in the deuce and I'm just walking
and do people saying so we used to get
these perverts you know me that want to
suck your dick
so yeah let's go back there we will be
the [ __ ] that we robbed um but
ass naked I don't I don't even know why
we did it why do you always want him
stripping them butt ass naked that's a
million yeah that's the deepest ability
Asian the reduce was Wow Yoda deuce was
Ellen in the tunnel yeah
because it was the street it wasn't a
club it was just like listen but you saw
everybody grabbing the grimy white
[ __ ] the crime in Chinese the
crime is black the crimeans put it
weakens the crime in 2 min to grind meat
only hunger no [ __ ] like right
now you're gonna know you got Disney
where everybody's able to eat them but
it's a time after you start attacking
and ripping my part my words my [ __ ]
children it'll rip those people apart
you start tearing them apart and going
in their pockets just ripping them right
now thank God because most my friends
didn't survive that this justice [ __ ]
people die I'm saying I've seen it I was
a part of it not like you know I mean I
wasn't no big drug deal or knocking
[ __ ] out and all right well you know
we did a little thinking I'm saying and
it's crazy to still be here man thank
listen I took I went I went to a Diana
Ross concert one time you know in Vegas
and I brought my daughter with me and
everything and I always knew from my
experience being a young boy yes don't
[ __ ] with Diana Ross
you know I mean she just knew where the
kids smack she was disrespectful people
try to play her she was smack you know
to put you in your place
and when she told me to come back I
wasn't on the street driving they said
come back and I came back and I met a
man I was thinking about the time when I
was a young kid well probably 76 77 I
was 11 or something 12 and I think mommy
she had a concert in Central Park and we
were young kids back then we were just
ripping people pocket out stick it
started raining and man really just
that's what the kind of life we live
back then man it's ripping these people
you know it's nothing it was to change
the person beating the [ __ ] out of them
we came with a crew look like 50 of us
and we rounds well yeah we just were
grabbing everything we've seen this kind
of thousand the people were grabbing
everything we see and now you sell bud
yeah when I was a little kid my pops was
from Quincy from Alabama NOLA but my
cousin's
Terry Carnell when Dale all them [ __ ]
is from Sterling and Ralph and and I
used to go over there
I used to have to stay with it for like
two weeks and it was like
one building on the block for real like
one building and all that other
buildings was like rubble and [ __ ] was
like to a scrap iron it look like a bomb
blew off a building like that I was on
that block for like two weeks that's the
first time I seen the real [ __ ] I was a
little kid I was like 13 14 fight for
everything gotta fight for your money
you want your money they with the code
they wanna [ __ ] you they want everything
[ __ ] you gotta fight picking a vertical
Johnson I'm picking in Belmont
this is take never been probably that's
crazy
feels good gym and blood and we do smoke
weed and lift weights yeah do some yoga
so you do smoke we do live weights
pretty much than I eat right you know
you meditate [ __ ] I never could do that
seconds be like I gotta go back I tried
I tried you know but that told have you
done it no I don't know
no I learned from y'all I'm wish I'd pay
big money to see sticky on that told me
to write what Martin
it's a crazy the toes if he never be
changed my life listen I was so I'm
ready to die I was just so [ __ ] up I
was thinking negative thought my life
was over it didn't have the money I used
to have so she wasn't right and I didn't
live in I having to create housing but I
didn't live in the house I used to live
in [ __ ] rout the house that I didn't
[ __ ] need the one with [ __ ] 25
bedrooms and I didn't have nobody that I
live alone and I got
and I got our house in DC now I got a
housing bigger here three [ __ ] houses
what the [ __ ] I got no and I got
staffs in my house they stayed my house
24/7 and so um that's who lives in my
house they live in my they got married I
wasn't even any got married lived in my
[ __ ] out my assistant my my workers
yeah that's crazy
the toad is a game-changing man yeah the
toad is amazing man it's got this
chemical called five Meo DMT you have an
ego death you die you meet God you come
back you think you [ __ ] up when I took
the toner hitting boom oh [ __ ] I tried
every joke come on give me the joke oh
[ __ ] when I got [ __ ] these white
[ __ ] got me sake got me I'm
[ __ ] around these white drugs and
they [ __ ] got my ass
listen I never knew what the [ __ ] you
mean I know don't know chemical this is
natural stuff that venom yeah this is
natural stuff listen you stay calm
please you think you think I've done a
different version of it I haven't done
the toad yet told thank you to that
level
another opportunity that you never want
to get hired again with no other drugs
after the toll that's a drink that comes
from a plant
this stuff is 5 m EO DMT so if I ask is
like the riverboat ride the toad is the
space now you just it's like it's like a
school yeah put on your tongue just rock
like this you take it on you be on a
Sutphin Boulevard train you pop the
train my time you can see the city you
rockin but your tray rise if you like
this [ __ ] on myself or something get the
farting stomach bubbler hurts I wanna
for bison [ __ ] that's the property out
there awesome the party forgotten
perform short performances you might get
y'all up to next a vocal music oh you
[Laughter]
said you're a big showing up did ya oh
this is yours I seen it I seen on you
made no I see something with this on the
word was
[Music]
yeah whose [ __ ] toe there's a great
thing you guys gotta come back to the
night yeah he's good he's one of those
good rappers that yeah security guard
you noticed our name again my inner sex
that was my mom and then she the bad
she's really hot
she was great too great performances Wow
y'all kept a hip-hop man that would be
perfect for onyx yeah definitely will
come in recon-car love we love the
nethers in a racing man is she you are
too that's why we talking right now we
just phase it a closer this is only the
tip of the iceberg about hip hop hip hop
is gonna put when we die it's going
please we never even dream that can go
you know imagine where it's gonna go
when we not here right like like with
all those place called misfits they went
there so now how could you be a misfit
these days pop a bunch of pills do some
crazy drugs and y'all y'all the new
misfits yeah pop speaks to that but some
of these guys got a lot of talent you
know ladies guide to doing these drugs
service stuff he's got a lot of talent
man he's got bad direction yeah this
[ __ ] is real huh oh
vicious man is vicious like we're look
fun right now make sure you know you
rocked out bodies built for the liquor
not for that stuff I
math stem is really bad smoke weed was a
real treat in water weed and water main
way to water a lot of a lot of real
drugs you know sex is a real drug that's
a yeah ii really needed to live imagine
that we abuse it
that's just like we mr. weed helps us
the TOA but we can't abuse it we be
abused elite sometimes you know i think
i just a matter of fact i like me i
smoke a joint that's maybe smoke to
raise a day I smoked some say whatever
put it
yo son I just smoked the most I smoked
like I just smoked for days or for we
just now made you like to work with I
want to work with everybody want to work
with us mm-hmm that's my politically
they're loving it my business you're
finding your love in there you never
know you know if things happen who knows
never said anything down whatever
whatever they show us love like my man
Tao Tao said they show you love you let
it go with a show you love it that's the
most that's like some real [ __ ] I always
keep in my heart he probably don't know
but that's some real [ __ ] and I always
allow it you got [ __ ] you got one club
everybody's trying to get in this club
you know I'm saying which of course this
amount for the table and all that but
this club they want you to come in they
got a table for you but so ass want to
go to this club my mom is like do that
make sense and you know each coaster got
to pay for everything and the West Coast
didn't give you the building don't got
paper you can clean the people you can
use that building that you performing it
and the way that matter of fact will pay
you to come to us just want to shout out
we want to shout out hip-hop and sports
you know them saying podcast we trying
to get pop in you've got want to shout
out the new onyx album with the
snowgoons you know I'm saying sticky
fingers album
you know I'm saying it's about Tom you
know I'm saying the honey lad album we
work in the conflict our dates you know
I'm saying on onyx HQ
snake easy for me yes yeah don't
realtalk [ __ ] as you're talking
toenails in effect
man you get a cleat in the toe yeah my
big mistake that she never did that when
she was talking [ __ ]
I was doing my shirt I couldn't believe
it like that was a movie like two men to
pay a price for that man you know I look
at myself now I'm very I'm very grateful
had the career that I had but man I
really uh instead of working smart I
really worked hard
mmm I didn't know how to work some more
didn't have I was a fight I work really
smart and working smart now with just
yeah but I'm putting my my body took
better care but you know what my
tomorrow you the more I destroyed my
body I thought that was everything
everything everything you think the hard
I'm tearing myself down it was us to
enjoy like not anything I say enjoyable
for all to witness and it all made
everything was everybody else we grow
superstars in the world like it [ __ ] is
real with everybody like me then that's
the good thing about life man we still
here like I said this morning when I
picked you that's the main thing that
the stick to me during my years and I
continue to make my journey in life how
many people that are lost a lot of
people there's loss at one time if I
lost somebody reason that we lost
somebody was because um somebody guys
somebody got into a fight my dissing got
to a fighter tried to rob somebody's
house got caught in the house and got
killed or something
you know those are the thing wasn't it
to somebody was to Mike dissing to cause
you to kill but like now when the drug
den came when game came in the eighties
the friends were killing friends here at
different spots you see friends we grew
up together
hustle pickpocketing what they got in
the drug game they started killing each
other
shoot each other a lot of [ __ ] in here
bro that's it's crazy
we see and I used to go train has to be
boxing I will come home back to
Brownsville and I asked one of my
friends you know he was hustling mm yeah
we're such answer and he was and this is
our best friend your best friend and
then you know I've been a wife I don't
know what's going on buddy knows and I
think we're such that he would go [ __ ]
that [ __ ] man this [ __ ] now we're all
best friends nothing that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] Mike we're doing this now yeah if
I kill me kill them we were best friends
it's like to see your guys work right we
just like they can only kill the mouse
good though with no stress now
everything is all like will you drive
your car your cruise control did it
already all the goal of [ __ ] the clubs
the parties and it's gonna be smashed
the best thing we did it with the best
we killed it killed the game now that's
what I think about my life that's all I
think about my life I can't believe I'm
here I'm gonna [ __ ] show them some of
this [ __ ] weed I'm the best time of
my life doing this most times people
feel like they're not worthy at the end
of the day you're talking about their
life and early you know because we've
been could we [ __ ] us up with nothing
we never could like you know mother rose
in the concrete theory Tupac used to
speak about like we can't belittle you
because your petals are broken or bent
you arose that group on the concrete
wanna do your mother told you that [ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] successful you get
ain't that the money no God take chances
way which were okay hunter that's the
truth [ __ ] right there oh yeah us then
that long all oh wow
well you get a different appreciation
we're friends
like this is a cup sit up sit up so the
I ball game yeah so I believe mom say to
the eyes just arise but probably we're
happy that way everyone involved yeah
you know all NFL player you know I'm
saying that no because he young
everybody but uh so and then might lose
my Yossi that's the way I got you cuz
you're young I got you but with my ol
ass got so you gots happy with the
younger people in because they got a
perspective that's all different and
it's good to elevate because if people
number for me fight don't know something
fine they think of me as the [ __ ]
actor from hangover
they think I'm an actor yeah some I have
to explain to them they're not an actor
because they know you from that and it's
crazy
yeah when they find out for the first
time
Evan I'm going to the school to talk to
some kids in my and this is when I'm
another time I even got crushed
I'm gonna do some expecting these kids
to know me I'm Mike Tyson I'm gonna see
these kid these kids what eighteen
seventeen so I go there and it's a big
movie screen bigger than as a big screen
and then watching my fights and then
watching my first of the teachers the
guy for my and I said yes the actors
from the hangover screen a perfect know
this is weird either funny show me fight
no idea who I was you know the kids
wanted to see your first off don't ever
see me fight
he was doing that to let them know who I
was I was like [ __ ] time flies hard to
keep up
you could be the baddest illest
[ __ ] to be in the funniest
yes brilliance like just and it's not
even as organic to but it's to move me
it was brilliant
nothing else you know I'm saying that's
what was about and like make it move so
we can take bang also young spirit also
gather some money with us also to get
real yeah I will find out you thank you
pretty nanny with you to money me think
that was [ __ ] hands that [ __ ] I get
my [ __ ] Jheri curls and waved and
[ __ ]
we had event we had to go through [ __ ]
to even get there like it up said s
curls and all that [ __ ] man big deals
god bless today's guest curling mom come
on but now girly [ __ ] on child you those
puppies you got in that you did you ever
get paid off and bison you know and by
Sisto his whole look who's in Vice I'll
see street fighter the move the the game
Street Fighter in the last they know but
they called them Balrog when his name
was m.bison first it would be like him
the boxing character
they switch the names that equation hey
where you guys going after ya have the
families go studio chill out enough soon
I go to a restaurant a song don't do
much sellouts movie create still working
these guys are working man everyday we
don't offer valuable time to be with
defenders we leave for like three or
four weeks at a time you know what I'm
saying so what we is like yo you know
I'm saying we got a really like you know
secure own basis [ __ ] I would never
leave for 3 or 4 weeks out of town it's
hard I know I was on the tour for like a
month more fit to come visit me we just
said I'm not to smoke some more weed
please help yourself go eat like you
want to wrap this so this is another
conclusion of them another great episode
of hot boxing I'm Mike Tyson I like to
thank the Onix for appearing here and
showing up and my man over there Johnny
Vogler the new man on the scene hell
yeah I'm having Britton thank you thank
you guys for listening thank you guys
for coming - no it's awesome man
really appreciate it - thank you hey
thanks man all right guys thank you for
coming until next time we are out of
here
[Music]